welcome back to las vegas now everybody
if you hadn't noticed summer is coming
so
it's time to talk water restrictions
with the southern nevada water authority
here's our conversation
we are talking summer mandatory water
restrictions because obviously it is
about to get
really hot in southern nevada so what
are those restrictions and why is it
important to have them here
so during the summer months from may
until august
you're never supposed to water from 11
am until
7 pm these are the mandatory watering
restrictions put in place
and it really is because that's the
hottest time of the day right where
evaporation occurs
so don't water from 11am to 7pm and as a
reminder
never water on sunday that's just
the rule of thumb throughout the year
and you're really doing this number one
to save water but
also because you don't want to get a
water waste fine we're really ramping up
on water waste investigations
and they can be pretty expensive they
started at 80 bucks
and double there after so and one of the
other things to think about during the
summer too is you're allowed to water up
to six days a week but that doesn't mean
that you have to
right now i'm only watering three days a
week how can we save money and save
water at the same time what are some
ways that we can do that so some of the
ways you can
save money is by number one complying
with the seasonal mandatory watering
restrictions
so four times a year that's all you have
to do is change your water and clock
four times a year and that coincides
with the seasons
and you can save up to 300 a year on
your watering bill by simply changing
those watering clocks
another thing that you can do is get rid
of that useless grass if you've got
grass in your front yard or on the side
of your house
and you're not using it get rid of it
and we'll pay you three dollars per
square foot
but you got to put in some water smart
landscaping and sometimes people think
water smart landscaping is just cactus
and rock
but it really isn't there's some
beautiful vibrant water smart landscapes
out there
you can head down to the springs
preserve gardens to get some ideas and
inspiration
and by doing so you're going to save
yourself some money on your watering
bill
you're going to save some time from
mowing that lawn and
fixing the landscape up and then most
importantly you're going to save water
and lastly here just give us some tips
on on
how to water yeah so your sprinklers and
then your drip emitters really need to
be handled a little bit differently when
you're setting it at your irrigation
clock
so for sprinklers we recommend the cycle
and soak method
so that's really kind of the short and
sweet
you're going to want to set your
sprinkler clocks for three cycles
for four minutes one hour apart and that
really gives you kind of the best bang
for your buck when you're watering it
gives a chance to soak in
and do the best for your landscape now
drip emitters are different you're only
going to want to do that maybe a couple
times a week during the summer
and and it's this is the longer the
longer flow and the time frame really
depends on if you have a
low flow or high flow emitter so it can
be anywhere from 20 minutes
to 90 minutes if you're if you're still
not sure what to do
go to our website snwa.com we've got
lots of great information
how-to videos and lots of really great
tips on how you can be water smart
all right you can get more information
at snwa.com